hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
make sure you subscribe so you get the
videos as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is are you garbage
it's a show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we found if they
grew up classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host stage foley coming
at you on a beautiful day down here
aunt tooty's basement spring has sprung
yeah
and it's beautiful outside i wanted to
report to you guys
i know you were concerned about her aunt
tooty
has the vaccine i heard i saw her
walking around in her hot pants earlier
she does she has the vaccine she's not
taking it but she
is selling it great she's got a couple
of doses to move
okay so if you know her hit her up she
might be able to straighten you out a
little bit
my co-host he's getting more and more
[ __ ] deadpan
that got darker such a letterman that
got dark my
co-host is coming at you unamused
oh i like him i love my left uh he's the
ceo of ru garbage uh international man
of mystery international businessman
he's got his skate gear on today which i
don't know who he murdered and had to
change in a walmart what's up ross
you are not this is not kevin if you're
a clone or what happened this is off
saks fifth avenue off off saturn
sixth avenue this is not off off ninth
avenue that's kippy kevin james ryan
gang hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes and a top 200
over there
a little review will help the boys out
also um
full video available on youtube i don't
know if you've seen those numbers but
they're
true to [ __ ] rooftop true to roof
true to roof
let's go get them going we can always
add another level
and then of course keep it moving of
course for the big boys patreon.com
are you garbage you can sign up you get
bonus content you get bonus episodes
ayg you get episodes of hard feelings
which is the [ __ ]
smash hit of the year the blockbuster
hit of the year those hard feelings we
got him
just me and foley chopping it up um and
then also we do a live stream every
month maybe one or two live streams a
month
with our top tier patreon members where
you ask us questions we ask you
questions it's a good [ __ ] time
good time get involved baby get involved
we love you guys very much thank you for
all the support a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinaire on
special right now
two golden brown english muffins slice
of american cheese and a big old zazich
give it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby
mcmullen yeah what uh
t-bone dude we're [ __ ] vaxxed waxed
and ready to suck some sack
dude let's do it we're all jack team's
all [ __ ] vaxed up daddy
team's all vac stop ready to go ready to
come to your town
a little foreshadowing a little foreskin
not a little gang this is a [ __ ]
family episode
all right and we have one of our
absolute favorites third time
guest here this guy he's the [ __ ]
paul simon of are you garbage
hey all right thank you art
we just finished doing his amazing
podcast last week with zakamiko called
bye guys
gang give it up for the pride of
delaware which is not
saying much saying a lot president from
delaware everybody else is ashamed
me invite him baby in finance ladies and
gentlemen
hey thank you for having me fellas
thanks for coming back i don't know why
you turned so corporate all of a sudden
i'm kind of regretting it i don't know
why hey thank you for having me
shout out t-bone good to be here
sponsored by
marvel oh marlboro lights his keys are
on the table some half drunk iced coffee
yeah
i was regretting asking as soon as you
walked in there with the bikes spilled
it in my helmet
let's go let's do this oh a helmet
coffee holder
let's go you have you're a guy that has
a lot of stuff
all the time always let's let's let's
jump into something quickly that we've
been wanting to do
empty your empty what's in your pockets
right i already got them on the table i
see there you got some clips in there i
see some other stuff
[ __ ] bandana a sheet of paper what
are you in the [ __ ] not one pen but
two in case it runs out of ink
oh my god light for the cigarettes i'm
i'm
getting ready for doom it's got a dog my
wallet which is just a rubber band
with nicorette gum on
that's right what's the what's the show
card there what what what's
what's the big bill on the end of your
flight just oh
hammy baby but that hides the hundos
dog you got a hell you do have a hundred
dollars i got some honey see that says
you're a weasel a gentleman puts the
hundred on the outside
no because you don't want to take this
out and have someone see it and think
you got money
all right they run the rest of your
pocket and find a [ __ ] mustache
yeah give me the money in a car and i go
no i gotta call him
what are you [ __ ] ethel from brooklyn
no you don't do that though rob yeah
no a tennis trap you got so many spaces
for things you got nothing in your
pockets
no no this is a show jacket that's my
why you get too close you might get
burned you're that guy
too you rigged the lighter so it's so
it's bigger oh
yeah what do you show that off at the
arcade who were you impressing with that
no one just myself you know go by the
elementary school
stay good come here you want to come
over i'll show you how to rig a lighter
oh here we go
all right that's the trashiest move
right you can't even do it
ready you might melt your rings don't do
it
it's soldered to my finger
and you're a big bike guy too you got
the bike out spring sprung and you're
excited huh i'm on the bike i'm pedaling
and meddling baby oh my goodness
something's kooky about this kid i don't
trust it i don't like he took an extra
dose of goofballs
took a piggy back at goofy's that's
right yep
thank you for coming in thank you for
sitting with us family episode as you
know gang when you sign up for patreon
uh we will ask your question on the air
we're gonna have a fun time here with
ian today
why a black band daddy you're so the
bandannas you're such a weird
why do you have car keys what are those
keys car key it's my keys in my
apartment and my bike
what is it what kind of what kind of
apartment you got nissan
what the [ __ ] who's got apartment keys
like honda this is for my youtube
this guy lives in a saturn this is for
my chain lock
this is for the front door this is for
the my apartment door and this is a key
to my friend's apartment in seattle i
didn't get back
you never know what i'm going to be in
the neighborhood wow oh man i made
dinner
i'm here you want a castle do you have a
storage unit you look like a storage
unit guys look at you live in a store
now
i just i have a bunch of stuff you don't
have any storage anywhere
you have anything stored at your mom's
in the garage uh yeah i have stuff in my
mom's house but nothing like that i
would need a storage uniform i think she
was like a box of like box of dummies or
like
those boxing dummies was he jeff
dunham she's like a racist pirate or
something
a tsa agent that's what i imagined man i
got my
i got my racist pirate hard-r
[Laughter]
i i think this is uh a reasonable that's
too much that's too much
don't you have a backpack too you're a
backpack no i don't have a backpack
what's in the jacket pocket you got more
in there this is where my smoke's going
then my mask is in the other pocket
i usually have a fanny pack when i ride
but that's got my bike gear and in case
i get a flat
you know that's got what in it your bike
gear yeah like a tube and um
little canister to blow up the tire if i
get a flat really
yeah you only get stuck in the streets
you kidding that was my biggest fear
during covenant it wasn't getting
code it was riding my bike and the bike
breaking down and getting eaten alive by
the homeless
here comes what i beat
come on jerry i give you a dollar
yesterday please
yeah i thought it was gonna be the
warriors trying to get home i was scared
[ __ ] take an uber what are you doing
taking over during the pandemic at the
beginning in april when we thought we
had to wash an avocado for eight hours
you think i'm getting in a car with a
stranger
[ __ ] you that's true i was real [ __ ]
nervous at the beginning of it oh
dude i know i wouldn't even look if
people were walking down my block i was
like yo keep it moving
well even now when i smoke in the street
i don't have a mask on
i'm in the middle of the street so i'm
not near people and people give me this
death stare
yeah you're in the middle of the street
man finances out again
oh [ __ ] please stop coming near me sir
we're police officers
yeah we're here to help you stay away
i burn myself so i don't get covered
i'll burn a germs
you must have been real kooky those
first couple of [ __ ] oh are you
kidding me bro
it was [ __ ] i mean i was in cats
completely shaved
you treat your own good mr mittens don't
worry
dude you made me laugh so hard it was
like march 16th and you had a boneless
just empty shell of a chicken you go we
ate the cat premature move if you ask me
well i was on twitter dude on instagram
holy [ __ ] yeah we got the roto that was
from the love affair with the roto hit
back dude i was so afraid
of of going places my laundry mat shut
down i washed everything in my tub
i was just like uh living on the prairie
watching things at the top
i'm going to my roommates i'm like i got
soap if you need it they're like nobody
they were in the tub at the time yeah
i'm trying to shower
we got to go to work we have to make
guys use his abs we can clean things off
we have to make the best of it here come
here jerry
oh man dude ian is so [ __ ] his chef
is jesus
what do you want i mean he was committed
[Laughter]
give me your toe i nails hungry can't go
to the store
i mean you were screwballs before this
all happened you think this was good for
me no
it's a [ __ ] nightmare and i tried to
quit smoking the first two weeks so i'm
losing my [ __ ] mind i'm thinking you
know
see that work didn't gum and the
marlboro lights oh my god i was [ __ ]
patching it up
double dig at the same time it's the
only way i can get high
so i [ __ ] was going nuts you know it
was it was a [ __ ] mess
we were all a mess right right
[Music]
all right it is weird though to think
back to this time last year
you know what i mean like i remember i
was at the grocery store i was all right
me too i when it was hidden i was like
is it gonna be a while two weeks
you know and then it just [ __ ]
wouldn't end then now everything's gonna
be fine it's wild
keep telling yourself that i like that
it's a good positive attitude you don't
think things are gonna be good
of course i think everything's gonna be
great things are opening back up here
man we're [ __ ] light
at the end of the tunnel baby yeah i'm
saying that anyway i'm saying i'm like
whatever
i i found out i was getting the vaccine
i was like oh i'm good i was just like
making out with people on this oh dude
you [ __ ] hit it right you went down
to the show oh yeah what the hell
i thought you were going to be talking
about how i obtained my vaccine
which by the way is the [ __ ] lip
sealed okay stop the show
sucked it out of aunt and let me just
say
did you get the vaccine
what'd they give it to you with a
harpoon
you did that before the show it worked
better now but i still didn't know what
you were doing you set it up like you
were [ __ ] megan mccain
henry he said that like he was in a
vaccine commercial
for old people like i was talking to
jeffrey gurion for a second
so i heard you getting the vaccine i was
at my
favorite podcast he's my favorite man i
love him he's the kindest dude
the best literally the best i can i can
look through his instagram for [ __ ]
hours upon hours it's good stuff
um i did i got the vaccine got the
johnson and johnson um
[ __ ] rocking and rolling nice yeah
good for you what'd you give
kippy um schmeiser ah
yeah i gotta go back and get my second
dose i heard you get sick after the
second it's like 24 hours
i don't know i'm all right now well
we're all gonna be fine right back
hey thanks for the update yeah right hey
cuomo relax let's go to toby with the
weather
jesus christ how about a feel-good story
before the break
i heard you get real sick after that one
speaking of feel good combos in the news
[Laughter]
ah guys a little handsy word on the
street huh everything that's happening
with him it just sounds like he's old in
italian
he's just like hey you haven't been with
an older man
how you doing wow yeah yeah yeah i'm
okay
he's old creepo for sure yeah good stuff
all right let's get out of some [ __ ]
business here enough goofing around yeah
you want to put your [ __ ] this isn't
[ __ ] county lock up
your [ __ ] away you ask me was it my
pockets and now you're
giving me [ __ ] huh he didn't mean
ten go be please
he's at 20. shut the [ __ ] up huh i'm
surprised he
see he didn't let go of the chopper when
it came to him if you could
please give me the hammy back thank you
stick
[Laughter]
it's fake money all right let's get into
some questions
hang on one second i'm sorry no of
course why do you have
how much money do you have on you uh i
don't i don't know
just enough he just worked this weekend
too so he probably got cashed up by a
hell of a cash
i got cash i tells a cash kind of guy
oh big time he's old school we got to
get him on here by the way put in a good
word that's why we invite you love it
call him right now i have don't worry
it's a big no
so you got so that's why you have cash
on you now
you'll go to the bank you know the
positive or you just let the will you
you use that cash
until it's gone no he uses it to start
up a game of three-card monte
is that true so henry i uh
also toby was [ __ ] killing last
episode everybody's like toby's the best
so he's the best big old
zilch on that one toby made a stinky the
secret to my powers is that i can cut
that out
and he's right back back on top
back with toby on the oh toby on the
weather all right let's um oh did you
want to
grill him on money or something you want
to ask me yeah do you want to see my
taxes what do you want you don't
typically roll with cash i tip you
you're more like bottles than candy when
i was like
rolling in cash when you were getting
spot pay
you always had cash on you and now i'm
working i don't think i've ever seen you
with money to be honest with you in your
hand
you're just recently started having your
own sigs on board yeah
always have my and they're hard packed
too you used to be a sophomore no i had
to get it from my deli
nine bucks a pack i talked them down
what's up do you really
are they new york no they're virginia
they are virginia i know
i don't know the spots 16 in manhattan
nine in my neighborhood
yeah my neighborhood my neighborhood's
ten and they let you do credit for it
too which is bananas
typically they with with the illegal
cigs they fly under the radar but they
don't put it down as cigarettes
well you're gonna find sandwiches you're
gonna find my guy he's an
eleven-year-old yemenis boy
you know he's really something hey boss
what do you want should we be at school
please i know you always see that play
they play it real fast and loose
he's smoking he has the attitude like
he's like he's 45 dude he's straight up
to the d hey
[ __ ] how much is a pack of batteries
i'm like jesus christ
boy yeah a lot of life experience i know
well when you're dodging bombs your
whole life it's going to kind of age you
you know what
i thought brooklyn was being gentrified
none of ian's comments are anyway
associated with are you garbage h fully
enterprises or
the tobey mcmuffin what are you hanging
me out to dry
what the [ __ ] i'm here to bite this
bullet of this [ __ ] loose cannon
i said what i said all right let's go
let's get into some [ __ ] q and a's
here huh
uh okay that was pretty funny you just
said this one's from terry t-bone aka
t-bone steak i don't know if that's a
if that's an homage to uh to t-bone
goddamn copyright infringement if you
ask me but you just did it have you or
the boys ever done the ric flair nature
boy woo in public
yes yeah that's a [ __ ] trash bag
movie what the [ __ ] how else do you
celebrate stuff
you slap someone in the chest and you
whoo go blow a guy at port authority you
were a big wwf kid growing up when i was
younger
little kid yeah yeah when i was cleaning
your mom and a headlock in high school i
convinced everyone to go to smackdown
and everyone's like all right we're
going i was the only one that brought a
sign
what'd your sign say i don't know i was
like help me
stone cold i'll blow you hang out with
me
[Laughter]
i did the same thing i went to i think i
went to something i made a sign too
yeah yeah i went to wrestlemania in
philly back in 99.
yeah me too yup i cried when dx broke up
remember that
uh yeah i was a big dx guy yeah yeah how
could you not be
going around suck it suck it yeah i got
in trouble for that
yeah we used to wrestle at recess and
i'll never forget this kid just stone
cold stuff
like his throat on shoulder and
everyone's like i think sonny's dead
he went to school with a kid named sonny
oh yeah he's only hold on his name was
sunny as an elementary school church
his nickname was sonny that's what
everyone called him his real name is
patrick
how do you get sunny i don't want to go
was he a wise guy what the [ __ ] he
wanted to be yeah
i wanted to be at one imma give him a
stunner a stunner
sonny two stunts
yeah that was big i had the dx shirt
that i bought at wrestlemania oh yeah i
believe
it was like a [ __ ] it went through
the wash and just
all the whole the whole [ __ ] saying
immediately i went to a buddy's bachelor
party in
2019 at smackdown or no
monday night raw really get him in the
podcast
[Laughter]
wwf man it was [ __ ] awesome for a
bunch of sober people what was the
wedding a cfl game
that's the [ __ ] shittiest thing
holy [ __ ] it rolled dude see the
juggernauts play
it's the sharks versus i don't even know
what you guys are talking about who's
dmx
what the [ __ ] are you talking about you
old [ __ ] you don't remember dx
yeah you were oh he's old 99 i was on
the run what are you talking about
yeah i was on the move as dx a percocet
dx80 you shop at dxl
dx pharmaceuticals very good company
hang on a second there gang want to talk
to you real quick
i know you've heard the old expression
if it ain't broke don't fix it well i
got a new one for you
if it is broke yeah fix it oh baby
especially if it's in the boudoir
or the bedroom as the americans say and
i got news for you gang what's that
your friends at roman can help so what
you want to do is you want to get to
get roman.com garbage
instantly yeah guys with roman you get a
free online evaluation and ongoing care
for ed
all from the comfort and privacy of your
home
office car wherever you feel comfortable
in private you can do it there baby no
prying eyes a u.s licensed health care
professional will help you
and find the best treatment plan if
medication is appropriate it ships to
you
free with two-day shipping so if you got
a hot date and you got something to take
care of two-day shipping easy peasy
the whole process is straightforward and
discreet no one's gonna have to know
you do you you know what i mean uh take
care of your ed without leaving your
home complete an online visit today and
connect with a health care professional
and take care of it get go to get
roman.com
garbage now and you'll save fifteen
percent off your first month
fifteen not five not ten i'm talking 15
baby it's really time to take care of
your a.d and remember get started today
and you'll save 15
off your first month of ed treatment not
bad just one more second there gang want
to talk to you real quick about the fun
we're having over there on the stereo
app
usually thursdays at nine o'clock come
by and hang out with us
it's a good time guys uh there's a lot
of good shows on stereo we're there
we're answering your garbage questions
live on the live stream
you get to send it in we answer it it's
a good time i have a couple of pops i
let my hair down
popping eddie enjoy myself fantastic
it's a good way for you guys to get
involved with the show and for us to
answer your garbage questions so
you go to www.stereo.com kevinryan or
slash h foley
link will be in the description we get
to wet our little beak uh
we get to wet our beak a little it's a
good time see you there now back
to the show oh man great question
uh next one is another [ __ ] home run
uh this is from kim hightower
do any women in your family drive a
pickup truck as their main vehicle
yeah no no
and then we had it for like camping and
stuff and then uh
i it was like my work truck for years
you still have it it's a ford f-150
you still have it it's only got like 42
000 miles on it i'm surprised you're a
two-car family
why i mean the obvious
dirt ball also i mean someone had to
pass away for him
we have two cars and then four on the
lawn
no tires on those we have four cars
three tires did you ever try to sell a
car when you put it out
on the front lawn when you park it on
the side no all showroom style
i didn't live on a barn i [ __ ] live
in a neighborhood
dude i did that when i tried to sell the
montego before i moved up here uh
by the way i got in an accident on their
way here i was trying to sell the
montego to get a couple of bucks to move
up to new york and follow my dream of
being
oh i remember when you [ __ ] put that
on a lot i put it back so my buddy
my buddy [ __ ] you right on the
windshield yeah my buddy lived
in like a high traffic intersection and
i just put it in his front yard
no offers at all dude obo is the child
you might as well say i'll take anything
yeah what do you got on here you got a
shoe i'll take it
25 grand obo it's always trashy if
you're trying to
sell your own car it's always a tough
look i don't understand it what's the
legality behind that
you just got to transfer the title yeah
that's it transfer the title and then
you take
don't you have to be a licensed person
to sell a car or something like that
no that just seems shifty it's not
percocet
did you go to school to sell this car
sir
did you pay your licensing fee i'll need
to see some sort of degree
yeah no dude you just sell the car you
transfer the title
okay i i i know people i that sell
their cars to their kids for like a
dollar they just transferred the title
yeah what kind of whip does your mom
drive by the way i was curious uh
ford uh f-350 no no it's way out of
highland
it's diesel no a uh toyota sometimes
bigfoot
nothing on that bigfoot that [ __ ]
[Music]
that's a folly's gonna lose
[Music]
diabetes took my bigfoot more of a
gravedigger kind of guy
it's also where he's gonna you know yeah
also he's gonna need a grave digger
after he loses his bigfoot and he's
gonna die on a sunday sunday sunday
you're going to want to bring the kids
to the funeral two for one
undertaker will be there
[Laughter]
and scene you gotta stop coming in like
this
[ __ ] giggling kids i know
got business to do also i don't know if
we said when you joined the patreon
we'll ask you to ask your question i
think we just got into it
i mentioned that i plugged it up top
okay who knows with you anymore
i know i'm the [ __ ] loose cannon
you're a [ __ ] cannonball
jesus i can do it cannonball oh i bet
you can
clear the pool out you guys mind if i
practice my cannonballs
yes you look like the kind of kid that
was you were probably mean to the fat
kid
no you weren't making fun of the fat kid
at the pool with his shirt on
no look at barney over there no way
too busy [ __ ] being scared of
everyone making fun of me
for what i hate buck teeth from here to
toby are you kidding me
his hairline was five years old with
this hairline
i used to have gorgeous girls i remember
dominique said you have the hairline of
a
battle stake
which is the funniest insult ever
the first line of a rattlesnake
man we used to have a good time oh those
group chats with the memes
yeah yeah dude when memes dropped in the
group chat for the first time
it was a game i remember i was by like
herald square and i couldn't get on the
track i was the same way then
overlapping
i was on break at work and i remember
like we all had to like agree to stop
oh my god i got a good time good time
all right
um this one's from tyler uh
i think both you do this um sleeping
with your pets
trashy or classy uh
why is it trashy i don't think it's
classy
i don't know if they're oh i know the
hair and the smell the dirt
i know when we came into uh bye guys
last week i didn't say anything but you
had
and you had more cat hair on your fleece
hoodie than a [ __ ] petco uh
well you know it's a lot it did
take care of cat hair i [ __ ] drew the
roller she fights back what do you want
no he dude he's been doing this thing
where in the morning he
like oh who
no my cat we're talking about betsy's
stupid [ __ ]
i was talking about cat hair i didn't
want to hear the [ __ ] day today
well you heard you should have heard
what he did this morning
i don't want to hear about mr whiskers
and all he wants to do is just lay next
to me and you know cuddle his name is
samson joseph respectively yeah
[ __ ] put some respect on his name my
cat kim kardashian
here's classy trashy do you put blankets
on your couch because of the dogs
like sheets on the couch put sheet my
mom put sheets
especially in the summer and to go back
to the question i apologize
it's [ __ ] real garbage but i would
never want it anyway that's
90 of why i have the pet so i can
snuggle with it i want right
snuggles yeah that we have a girlfriend
for
yeah but it's different it's me mommy
and baby in the bed and baby gets a
little blanket over here
skin crawl and
if i happen to go to my parents without
her you know if she's not coming or
whatever
you're all the dog the girl
the golden retriever is always sleeping
with me daisy's coming right up to bed
and we're snuggling all night yeah
absolutely what kind of psychopath
doesn't want to snuggle with their pet
i just i think it's did you grow up
without pets i grew up
i grew up with it he did but he didn't i
had multiple
they lived next door it was weird i
don't know dogs live next door
like parents that don't get along he
paints this picture that i didn't have
pets i had pets all growing up i had
pets until
junior high high school junior high yeah
did you walk it and feed it and all that
kind of stuff no the butler did
yeah i [ __ ] walked at your [ __ ]
also we had a yard we put them in i
don't know just doesn't seem like you
had
you don't you don't strike me as like
like a snuggly guy
i don't strike you as a girl man who
talks to his cat baby
what are you talking about thinking i'm
doing it you're doing it in front of a
podcast for the tens of thousands they
don't know the cat
i'm not doing a tuner at work or
something like that you have a cat and a
dog
no i have a cat my parents have a dog oh
okay what's a cat's name
majora
you can leave but that's your cat's name
david bowie dave
starbuck majora
majora yeah you ever go to labia no i've
heard the bit i've heard the material
though thank you
you've never seen it i've heard about it
i've seen magazines hope to see you one
day
i have special movies where i see it
so you think it's trashy to snuggle with
the pet i
he's not he doesn't like that [ __ ] he's
he's he's a cold crude individual
there's no affection there i haven't i'm
a pure affection i don't know what
you're talking about
i mean you're looking through me right
now i was looking down the barrel on the
camera
this guy's got a cold stare i love human
contact
by the way your knees touching my knee
not happy about it i know you got the
jimmy leg too
you're all over the place by the way
people are complaining that the table
jiggles every time you talk
i have to i have to break i have to
bring some iron workers some thin
knockers in here
to reinforce this [ __ ] thing while
while you're home
[ __ ] rolling around with the cat i'm
in here [ __ ] with attack welder okay
jesus christ breaking my balls over
affection
cleaning up all their broken furniture
that you live in in your wake
it's like in gilbert grape when they had
to reinforce the floor downstairs and
they didn't do it behind me that's
crazy yeah i had to put an extra
security deposit down here
will he be taking the no i just think
it's i don't know it's just dirt i don't
know as i got older
it's just dirty i don't know the smell
the hair
it's just not for me it's dirty if
you're
like wash your pet's paws from being
outside then
are you doing that every day you're not
washing your pet's paws every day
i mean when i i'm not watching my paws
every day
by the way i've
wait wait you said it was glue yeah and
on your face
i don't i don't want to tell you where
it was
on the tip of your microphone yeah it
was in your area
laugh it up douchebag
it's elmer's yeah he goes oh it's glue
for my phone and i'm like well
all of a sudden your phone's a glue
factory you got glue on your phone
my blood sugar was low it wasn't it
wasn't my best lie
i'm not [ __ ] nominated for a critics
choice
that's majora juice i was petting the
dog one thing led to another
that reminds me when we were kids i was
talking about this this weekend when we
were kids
uh we convinced this dog our buddy's dog
uh was humping our other friend and we
were like hey dogs can't come he's like
oh this thing's gonna come on me we're
like dude dogs can't come
and we're like he's like what we're like
yeah the female comes and he's like all
right so we were like just doing it as a
dude this thing dog had its balls yeah
wow they're just red rocketed
lucy i forget what i want do this thing
god damn right he did all
over him dude to try to live that down
as an eighth grader ain't easy
he got calmed on by a dog yeah if you go
to a different school
how do you survive yeah it was a tough
luck for him
did they end up getting married
it was also one like we made fun of it
was also one of those things it was like
we were like you felt bad after a while
you're like all right man we've just
been crushing this dude i mean you gotta
become like you just gotta start
punching people oh there's no way you
can
like live that down without just
fighting kind of dog was it
it was like a poodle damn look look oh
my gosh oh he got calmed on by a dog
named fluffy
yeah yeah it was like a little white
poodle like one of those big
not the weird european not like the tall
skinny it was like a short little
i don't know [ __ ] something short
little horn balls
i don't know i had a couple of drinks
it's all wrapped up i know that much
i had a little lipstick out too
seeing that for the first time as a kid
man that blew your hair back
you've seen your dogs you got to do a
double
[Music]
do you ever see the dogs that just have
like a quarter of it hanging out all the
time
like dude what are you doing read a book
or something just running around with a
push pop
yeah yeah you're like dude take a
[ __ ] you know looking like this
lighter yeah take a shower or something
the north americans ready to go
[Laughter]
that was the dog breed i didn't know
you're talking the north american ready
to go
sounds like a [ __ ] sounds like a bad
football team
oh man that was that was bad all around
cut that out north american ready to go
you two didn't keep it in the air either
i didn't know that got shot down like
duck hunt
that was a system of failure right there
we got a reboot
norad shot that one out of the air
that's a [ __ ] week-long callback for
the listener
we did that we did that a week ago last
week fully snore rounded up
everything's lower what do you [ __ ] a
door head what are you ignoring
all right these are just [ __ ] bonkers
oh
and it's bonkers i think i got boogers
on me now that i think about it
um if not i got you
all right this uh this is from fart
vandelay have you ever gone out to eat
with your friends and only ordered water
knowing that they wouldn't finish their
food and you'll get to have their
leftovers
you would think i'd say yes but no
really no i pegged you i dude i saw that
one i said i'm saving the chariot
no no way i didn't
you got to do the water at like burger
king or something and then you get a
soda
i don't even do that that's too yeah i
can't do that
you've never done that going can i just
get a cup for water maybe
it's not worth the anxiety of getting
called out i'll give you the dollar 19.
i got the cash
i just said i wouldn't go i used to hate
that [ __ ] when i was a kid if i had
money
i wasn't going anywhere and then people
would try to pressure me to go just come
i'll get you something and you get there
and they [ __ ] make a big deal
i would go but i wouldn't no way i
wouldn't order anything but i'm not
getting a wall i'm just here to smoke
yeah yeah that makes you weird that
always made everything uncomfortable the
one person that wasn't eating
wait was that guy's name fart vanderlay
oh no no i apologize fart vandegay
i stand corrected mike when you think
you can't get any better very nice yeah
i know
that was awesome fantastic name um all
right this is from john beale have you
ever put a glass of milk back in the
fridge
oh yeah yeah i don't i can't do that i
had a roommate that did that he would
drink a half a soda or whatever and then
put it in the fridge
yeah what's wrong with that in the
bottle
no in a can what's so bad about that the
air's gone you come back
nuts if you come back two weeks later
put your hand on it give it a little
shake
it's not bad what you never done that no
you finished a can of coke like a
[ __ ] gentleman
no you put it back in the fridge i'll
tell you
flat coke tastes good flat coke does
flash soda does taste good especially
when you're real thirsty
yes good night yup in the middle of the
night you get a little oh
across the bottom of a [ __ ] two liter
of ginger ale it's been in there for a
couple of weeks
you guys are [ __ ] happy but he's
giving me the hard no over there there's
a hotel room over the weekend
like dr pepper on the night stand
drinking in the morning
i'm not saying i haven't done it but i
don't [ __ ]
do it i don't i'm not going out of my
warm dr pepper first thing in the
morning
you ever do that you wake up who needs a
smoothie you just need sugar or
something
you do that late night scoop of peanut
butter yeah
they're stuck in the rooftops of new
york in a craze
you don't eat in the middle of the night
do you what
you're not waking up to eat not children
or anything like that
i don't know what you're insinuating
not like a middle night to eat he
doesn't even go to sleep he shows up all
night eating
i'm like a shark i just keep slowly
moving around if
do you keep food next to the bed i keep
uh yes a pork chop in my [ __ ]
food i got if i get a hankering for a
t-bone what do you think i have a
[ __ ] dessert cart next to me or
something like that
he's one of those things he's got a
cardboard box of mice that he feeds on
every hour on the hour the towel
sticking out of the mouth
i have one of those pie things i think
if it wasn't
for your girlfriend you would keep food
in the bed just closer next to the radio
hit a snooze have a chip hit the snooze
have a chip
it's the refrigerator in the hallway the
cord's pulled as far as he can
he's got candy bars in the bed frame
like heavy weights
oh god no dude no
surprising what were we talking about
what was the question
i don't even remember um have you uh
oh go out to eat and don't order i had a
buddy that did it religiously
like we'd be like my buddy that's no
shame yeah yeah yeah i wasn't that kid i
had a lot of shame
yeah same here i would spend my last
three bucks to not look like an [ __ ]
yeah get the mozzarella sticks or
something you know what i mean
keep up appearances
i would go hang out but not pay because
i i
eat like sometimes i'm just not hungry
and i i would just go to hang out and
not eat but we used to go to oh
oh this is trash 14 we used to go to a
diner called the ranch house
and if you even the water you ordered
coffee
and if you'd ordered like food so we get
the cheapest thing which was like um
uh potatoes or what's it home fries
we just get home fries coffee and
cigarettes and eat that
always have money for uh a little bit of
home fries at 14. i'll take a baked
potato please
real cool kid yeah when'd you start
smoking
cigarettes yeah uh not until
after high school really yeah i mean
maybe a couple in high school
that's surprising but that's that's
about it wow yeah i was probably
12 13 12th grade probably 12
quit start again 13 14
quit and then again at 21 full steam at
health
man like pat you own you had your own
packs
no i stole them from who my mom what'd
she smoke
true blue remember those silver box sure
yep they had the thing inside didn't
then they have a little different kind
of filter
yes it was like it was like a circle
with a little
yeah oh my god i've never felt close to
you in my entire life
jesus christ you start crying i'm not so
bad right now
mama god damn true i'm glad you're
smoking again
i gotta get off it it's bad it's tough i
gotta get off it i'm trying to get off
it
i'm trying to say that to somebody
misery loves company yeah there's
nothing better i'm sad you quit
i'm glad you're back on the heroine yeah
yeah uh there's nothing better than
going outside especially after a pod
having a bernie letting the [ __ ]
you know letting the adrenaline come
down off the bike earning it
smoking three to make up for lost time
it's a disease people
it's a disease um uh this is from andrew
uh has anyone in your family ever owned
a can crusher
no no they're kind of a new thing i know
they're not
that i used to go to kingdom houses yeah
you step on it and that was always fun
yeah you stepped on it in one shot you
know we used to always do
two was uh if you had a juice box you'd
blow it up as much as you could
pop it and then pop it yeah i was huge
shout out to high c they knew what they
were doing man if there was one thing my
dad did right did a lot of things wrong
but if there was one thing he did right
was keep the house stocked with
high c orange and fruit punch dude
high c orange will [ __ ] twist your
eyeballs back dude in the juice box
it was better out of the juice boxes
than it was the jug
she tried pulling the jug sometimes i
was like you you yeah old man go back
to the jug always sometimes they would
you know what we had we had the can
the [ __ ] oh yeah yeah with the you
actually had to open it
one of those things open when the cold
air really got to it in the fridge
yeah i can feel the chemicals in it oh
so you're drinking it cover it with
saran wrap no let it rock
you gotta let it breathe like [ __ ]
red my mom would pour it into a to a
pitcher
oh we went straight can i left it in
there yeah
damn that's not good that's that's how
you get uh you're old with a can like
it's
[ __ ] schlitz or yeah yeah that was a
big it was like a big like cork
you don't know you know those things yes
yes and then you had the triangle yeah
yeah
yeah it is we didn't know what was
happening you weren't supposed to leave
it that's how you get like legionnaires
disease or something maybe that's what
happened to my hairline
i'm gonna i'm gonna sue big big juice
legionnaires it's leaving there
thanks for coming by it was fun see you
guys later have a good one
all right let's see ah this will be this
isn't this is probably this is where
foley could paint his masterpiece this
is from
uh romero first time on patreon
um what was your favorite after school
snack or snack combinations if there was
multiple as a child
well i'll get home around three o'clock
dim the lights change into my street
clothes
[Laughter]
did you wear a uniform to school yeah
you went to public school yeah i was the
only one
he's in a janitor's outfit better get
used to it fatty
did you call them street clothes dressed
like a pilot uh gym teachers called them
street clothes
i said street clothes last week i still
say no my mother would know just street
clothes
what are we in the [ __ ] for when you
get it welcome back carter what the [ __ ]
street clothes
welcome back carter
that's just jimmy carter sitting there
welcome back
[Applause]
he's carter carter on the brain he was
talking about him before the show
uh they left to my devices and i was a
fat kid and whatever would be at the
house i would have to make do because my
mom would be at work
my brother and sister would be gone or
whatever or if they had already moved
out or whatever
i they moved out of the young age i
would do
the the most to try i would drink slim
fit a can of slim face
i thought it was like chocolate milk i
would i just drink a slim basket and
appear through elaine bryant i would
drink a slim fast and have a
have a thing of uh herbs pretzel nuggets
take a diet pill stop cleaning the house
i would
before i get dinner started i'll have a
slim
fat what kind of [ __ ] i thought it
was chocolate milk i didn't know what if
i was drinking it like
you're drinking slim faster you're fat
as hell i know i'm dude dude i'm doing
bite and sip with pretzel nuggets like a
[ __ ] animal
a slim fast is a whole meme i know i
know dude what kind of fat kid were you
man
i don't have time to chew after a couple
of weeks i was like well i'm not gonna
be on the commercial for this one
this ain't working i was blowing up
flash slim fest and four lean cuisines
shout out to lean cuisine they got me
through some tough times oh chicken
teriyaki
always cold in the middle
those stuffed shells never cooked in the
middle i'll tell you god
just like that cookie and the hungry man
you ever do that uh we were never hungry
we were
like we were a step up we were we were
big hungry definitely
still a good man right now
wait wait i have a question for all of
you eat them frozen have any of you ever
gotten
food from a dollar store
i knew yeah frozen food would bro you
would get absolutely not
i don't even like [ __ ] buying [ __ ]
from walmart or uh
or target they got food now yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm not into it i don't trust
the orange juice i don't know what it is
that's the thing you don't trust it's
too close it's not the meat
nah do they move product that things
that shit's all brand new the turnover
on those is
bonkers yeah it's it's it's better there
than it is your [ __ ] acme
what are you the regional manager i just
know they move units dude i've worked in
retail and grocery
i was at my place and he was like he was
like you want some broccoli i was like
yeah he goes it's from the dollar store
so it's mostly stems
oh my gosh i don't mind a nice step just
a shitty vegetable dealer
i only got stems and mids mostly rubber
bands but
that's fantastic what the [ __ ]
i'm sorry blows
what the [ __ ] was that one last name
i'm sorry how did that even nobody even
said anything it was the one last image
of the broccoli that people
said popped into my head we gotta we
gotta
clean this up this is a mess keyboard
help me out
this guy gets vaccinated starts marking
his territory
i'm trying to spread the ant at least
it'll clean up the boogers
oh that was what they showed at the
beginning of covid
i like what people talk yeah talk about
this
it's the [ __ ] river
can you throw me the paper towel
whatever you do cuomo whatever you do
don't do this
dude that was the most insane thing i've
ever seen in my life i always thought i
don't
i didn't it was like you got like jfk
got shot i thought your head exploded
to the left
and he's fat and to the left
dude i literally thought i i thought
someone shot you in the head
at the way you missed dude it was i
literally thought you took a
time back and nam dude i would stop man
my [ __ ]
jesus no you're killing you that was
[ __ ] out of control
that's his reaction when he hears the
word broccoli
it's an involuntary
that was just too much oh
it's all over here this guy's pankos
[Music]
they won't got me i don't know you got
you i don't know what to
tell you jesus christ
and nobody even said anything funny it
was a 10-minute delayed reaction
like two seconds after he said after i
said the rubber band i thought of one
more image of the of the
situation ah man
paige wants to know if you ever owned a
back scratcher
[Laughter]
which are trashy i gotta say i'm a fork
guy whoa
oh you put it back in i think we might
have talked about this oh
you don't wash it off i'll do it while
i'm eating shut up
i'm eating he's got [ __ ] tomato sauce
all over his back
uh i had a buddy the we were in a
backscratcher family i had a
i remember going over my buddy's house
and his whole family was just sharing
one like sitting watching tv
oh what and i was like dude i was like
uh
no it was i i felt like i was at an orgy
can you call my mom yeah i didn't know
what was going on
i knew it wasn't right though it wasn't
by the god did not approve it
yeah it was weird you ever have the head
scratcher my wife has one that's
nice yeah it feels that's good they
always bend i don't like them my wife
does it
it's not for me you don't like your head
not like
give me a hand give you you know give me
a meat hook or something you know what i
mean
you sit next to him
[Laughter]
i don't even know what you mean a meat
hook a hand yeah like something i need
some [ __ ]
you know i need like a massage i don't
just need like some little metal [ __ ]
you're not doing it right i'm doing it
right
we've got them we've got multiple i put
them on my pp sometimes
and she's out of town it's like a robot
were you a back scratcher family me yeah
i've told you honestly uh just
my dad was big on scratching his back on
the corner of the wall
i kind of adapted that you know
it feels great you got a nice corner
especially with like a little stucco or
something on it
like a popcorn wall it has a little
texture always food with you
[ __ ] nice the foleys are just
philadelphia brown bears
nah never a backscratcher family i'm a
shoehorn guy
i like a good shoehorn that's good do
you probably could use the long one so
you because you can't bend down i
presume
well i mean that's pretty rude of you to
say yeah that's true
put the shoes on a boomerang
[Laughter]
yeah no i use the long one it's easy
feels good you ever
[ __ ] your thumb up from using your thumb
as a shoe horn
no i think so how hard are you putting
your shoes on
you're pulling gotta go
never someone's listening to
thunderballs but you're going out and
buying a shoehorn
ordered it on amazon i think it was
prescribed but yeah
my guy in footlocker gave it to me hey
listen what's your copay
you better take this you're probably not
that far off from
prescription shoes either oh my god i'd
love a pair some orthopedics
um measured oh yeah good you're close
slip-ons you're close couple wide ones
when you can't wear jeans the orthopedic
shoes are next
get orthopedic jeans
they're just like normal you like turns
all right let's run through a couple
here we got a couple of minutes left
with the old ian uh
animal um this is from wet rat whale i
don't think we've done this
will you fill up the soap dispenser with
water when it's low yes
yeah i have that currently at the moment
i just actually just
just bought new soap you do it with
shampoo yeah
yeah discuss this yeah yeah the problem
with that is when you don't realize the
next day and it's already cold
water and you get [ __ ] talk about a
[ __ ] talk about blue balls
you gotta do it for the little uh
layover before you get the old soap
or you gotta think ahead and get
multiple things of soap so you don't
have to go back
sure yeah are you a one at a time guy
i'm not
i'm like let me buy ten of these so i
don't have to think about it you go and
buy toothpaste you buying one or a
couple
i'm buying one you're buying one yeah
toothpaste is a little bit i guess not
though
i don't know one or two depending a lot
of times they
they'll do the double pack yeah i'll buy
that double joint what's your brand
i do i use the [ __ ] tough stuff the
arm and hammer advanced whitening
you ever you ever brush your teeth and
put baking soda yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i did that in the 90s and my mom's
everybody did it my mom's like this
works and i remember being like this
is not for your mouth it doesn't do
anything yeah it does no it what all
this
all the toothpaste has baking soda in it
yeah not the old stuff
no but i'm saying so it works i'm i'm on
his side i'm saying it works if they're
putting in the toothpaste to work
you got to double dip sensodyne and arm
and hammer
so i got such pearly white dines for
[ __ ] i use sensitive all the time
yes yep it's the best that's one of
those things that if i would have asked
for sensitive
like i would it would have been like i
didn't use a bully disappears
my dad would have been like what are you
what are you no way get out of here
or a crest family or colgate we always
wanted aqua quest
aqua aqua you have the push down thing
with the two
my buddy matt had that and it blew my
mind oh yeah remember that
we didn't get it but i remember it and i
remember the commercials that was
hot and you try to make it look like the
little wave of course
this is like one of his first bits oh
really every time i do it mine looks
like bird [ __ ]
have you guys ever seen the like the the
trashier version of that
where you stick the toothpaste into the
holder and then there's like a roll
oh that's real trash to get the last
little ounce out
get the [ __ ] out of here or people like
i've seen people cut it open it's like
oh we cut it over dude
keep it moving yeah we've cut it open
squeeze out the bottom
never cut open toothpaste first of all
that's funny [ __ ] no
no not get out much huh you ain't a cat
hanging out hey what are you saying we
cut open a coke scratching their backs
against the corner
i can't hang out tonight guys i'm
cutting open some toothpaste
there's a little in there there's a
little in there no you you roll it
yourself
then when it's done rolling you grab
sure i love
oh god when you roll it and then the
sides and you bend the sides in just to
get that last little bit i gotta
i gotta yell these [ __ ] arm and
hammer [ __ ] it always
cracks my every it's only the only tooth
has ever had it [ __ ] breaks and then
like there's a hole
and you can't get the [ __ ] back hold
on is your
is the tube metal still no
you sure it's not like that aluminum no
no
yeah like when you squeeze it it breaks
and it breaks around the little nipple
and there's like a hole there and then
you can't get enough [ __ ] juice going
i think you're breastfeeding too late
it's not breastfeeding if it's your wife
[Laughter]
all right uh let's do two more here i
was from james smith
uh hey first question asked is it
garbage to wear an old work uniform as a
last minute halloween costume to a party
[Music]
it's pretty good thinking in my book i
don't fantastic yeah that's [ __ ]
stick and move save 25
always go for comfort why not yeah of
course
like the one of the pep boys or whatever
you know i think after a certain age
going to a halloween party is trashy
i think that yeah they're not they're
fun but
it's interesting to drink i can't do
that well i would i would pull the move
of i'd throw like a penny on or
something like that and a hard hat i'm
not
like a quarter right i can't do 1.50
[Laughter]
i can't do like the face painting stuff
i'd be too uncomfortable oh no i mean
what adult is painting their face
people do the whole costume you know i
mean they they get into it
people like halloween i like halloween i
just can't do the face cause i'd be
eating and [ __ ] like that i don't want
that makeup all over me
get hot and greasy yeah i just remember
i do something easy a wig and a jacket
or something yeah
i remember being real hot and real fat
and real sweaty when i was a kid at like
halloween parties
yeah as a kid
kids are locked in today boys yeah dude
i
i uh one year it was when the phillies
won the world series i went as a
phillies fan
because i went to the parade and then
just stayed in my clothes
would you watch a cop no all right
uh let's do two more here this is from
calvin witt have you ever gone on
vacation to a resort that had a washer
and dryer and brought dirty laundry with
you
what i've done oh did i pack dirty
laundry for sure
especially going down the shore i packed
dirty yeah because you have a short
house yeah but you're not going to a
[ __ ] radisson with dirty clothes i
had radisson money maybe
are you you were your hair up in a bun
it's laundry day what the [ __ ]
i would if i knew they had lymphatic
vacuum cleaner
i liked the dirt devils oh if you had a
dirt devil you were garbage oh wow i
thought they were classy
oh get out of here what it was better
than the dust buster
no i'm talking a full-size dirt devil oh
no we're not animals we had the little
guy
yeah if you had that if you had the big
red dirt devil [ __ ] vacuum cleaner
your mom was chewy yeah yeah vacuum
salesman
electro yeah remember them my mom i
think that's how my mom bought all of
them
i think that's why i eat so much
i think she bought both of our like main
vacuum cleaners growing up off uh
door-to-door salesman yeah wow i think
so electrolux
sweet talkers we had an electrolux i
don't even know
gray i don't know not right it wasn't
the same one relax dork
you stole that from me and my mom
was it named rusty that's my vacuum
cleaner man
give it back they were all gray what the
[ __ ]
i'm making colors about different colors
i'm sorry i'm trying to find common
ground
well he's upset you're both upset about
something so insane
we'll always have the true blues huh
love you buddy i love you
[Laughter]
all right this is from will campbell uh
were you ever really into guitar hero
no thank god oh man i was i [ __ ]
hated that i was bad at it i was good i
thought i was glad i was good i told
people
our hero ruined songs for you yeah i
can't hear any of those
i can't hear some of those songs without
just having this
he's sitting there red blue green red
blue green red green green green green
green
it's just it ruins so hang on here comes
this soda carry on my way
and it's just you hear it now it's like
[ __ ] that and rock band and like people
get that was big dude
i was in college maybe that came out
that was the first that was you know
and you hang out have a couple of beers
oh yeah you're getting slammed playing
[ __ ] the drums on rock bands
yeah nintendo wii we would do when we
dropped
we bowling oh we tennis holy good
[ __ ] time yeah i also found out all
you had to do was just
this oh really dude i was like running
around my living room [ __ ] knocking
over vases and [ __ ] like an [ __ ]
and then my buddy came over and just
started doing this and he was whooping
my ass i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah you got the outfit on everything at
the gloves
i'm mac
[Music]
all right let's do two more from the
facebook group and then we'll get out of
here uh this is for matt have you ever
given
uh your pet an alcohol or drug related
name
like jack daniels or [ __ ] you know
whiskey oh that's not true i'm lying
this is my boa constrictor psilocybin
probably had a durable fentanyl
how he shoved it up his ass well i think
fentanyl got out
it did no he's okay
he's really okay uh
we our last golden retriever all right
our baby was uh damn yingling
america's oldest brewery and that's
right pennsylvania's tragedy is just
smoking indoors type living
that is he was the best dog ever too it
did [ __ ] haunt that he was
what the hell does that i don't like
you're insinuating mr finance
i was never inappropriate that was that
dog dog named yang link
oh he was the best that's tough because
it was just when
it was when the um when lot when when
yingling lager got
real like it was blowing the [ __ ] up in
pennsylvania
it's always been i mean it's america
it's from like 1872.
yeah see you don't know what you're
talking about because you're a [ __ ]
pinhead
all right they didn't use that recipe
until much much later
they found it in like the recipe card
and then they started making jiggling
lager
and that's when they caught it we gotta
buy a dog and name them after the new
recipe ma
here the recipe's coming out get the
pomeranian
barbecue like you can't get this dog
under the mason dixon the calories too
we couldn't buy the dog on a sunday
that's a commonwealth what are you gonna
do we named him what we traded for him
[Laughter]
all right all right uh last and not
least this is from chad do you
which i just i don't know do you not
cover food when you use the microwave
ah it's a pain in the ass i've never
covered food ever
even like spaghetti it splatters
everywhere yeah you've got to cover
microwave spaghetti a microwave cover we
have one now we have the
the like the plastic one with the fence
in it that's great
i've never done that ever yeah if you're
microwaving soup or something it pops up
i just i just let it roll which is every
night for you
i mean i mean if you're in a [ __ ] jam
daddy
you've never microwaved soup i have but
i've been in jams that's what i'm saying
you didn't get cans of soup at the
beginning of quarantine no
oh yeah i trade them with the homeless
people cracker jack
burn them over fire cooking what's your
go-to soup in
cream of mushroom you're more of a split
pea kind of guy ah
tomato soup and grilled cheese all-time
favorite
and possible man you need a hug you
don't like
you don't like tomato soup and a grilled
cheese come on now delicious
basically you look like you inject it
it's fantastic
yeah wait pizza i'm talking we're
talking about the cans can of soup
oh can of soup i love uh broccoli
broccoli soup broccoli delicious cream
of broccoli cream of broccoli soup yeah
from campbell's that's what you would
get it's delicious
or potato soup
i can't do campbells amy's is top shelf
amy's low sodium split pete never had
amy's
what is amy's it's the organic brand
never had you never saw amy stuff in the
frozen food
does a pretty good job annie's mac and
cheese
i've had i've had marines pretzels
annie's mac and cheese i know what
you're talking about
that's fantastic that's that's the top
shelf mac and cheese yeah it's pretty
good
never had annie's don't something look
forward to ann's
he's not a [ __ ] floozy okay it's ann
dan
[ __ ] annie so they used to call me a
wrestling king amy
no anne because they didn't say ian they
said ann
and because they're [ __ ] derelicts
from delaware yeah shitty ass
and monsters i was in wawa this morning
and there's the
the cashier what what where out i was
down
i was came from the shore i was down the
shore and i stopped at a wawa to get a
coffee and the woman goes
ah beautiful weather out there i go yeah
she i was like yeah it's real nice i
ain't complaining she goes
i can't wait to go home and open my
windows and i was like oh my god
to my car i left my kids in there i
can't wait to go home and open my
windows
just smoke out the window oh man
you get a nice cross breeze it's nice
let's wrap it up big man
gang this was absolutely fantastic ian
thank you much for sitting in with us
and uh hanging out with us on this
family yeah we love you guys what do you
got to folks out there to know
uh bye guys every thursday 11 a.m on gas
digital very funny very fun part we just
did it yes
very fun ian's inviting playlist every
friday at 1 p.m on siriusxm channel 99
uh with plays all through the weekend
and on the app and um
i animal69 on twitch twitter and
instagram
here it is t-bone that vaccine really
[ __ ] my [ __ ] up
the vaccine went right to my funny bone
my teeth are falling out
instagram at toby dobbing you never
asked me i don't know what's going on i
thought i do
no you never do kevin who
i panic uh guys as always thanks for
listening please make sure you
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube patreon.com guys
thank you so much for all the [ __ ]
support on patreon
we're [ __ ] cooking baby news hit
check the news the [ __ ] patreons
cooking
that's right and at cameron comedy on
all social media
gang we love you we'll see you next week
peace
hold on hold on hold on [ __ ] back down
kevin ryan i want to tell the folks one
more time before they get out of here
what's that big man i want to let him
know about the old stereo app there's
amazing shows on there love that stereo
sign up for free you either have an
android or an iphone it doesn't matter
they can sign up
they can listen to the show listen to
the shows you got great people on there
we're on there every thursday at nine
usually usually yeah
uh guys we're doing a show once a week
it's like an after show and after party
type thing
you join q a join that stereo app we're
taking your garbage questions live
we get a couple hundred people in the
party you know it's a nice after part a
little vip section you know
they're very exclusive so check it out
go to www.stereo
kevinryan or slash h foley the link will
be in the description of the episode
click that link
we get to what our beak you get to
listen to the show it's a good time
peace peace